and then robert then walked in and i
realized i've been talking to his stunt
double the whole time
complex fights and terrifying jumps
never fail to impress
but sometimes the person you're watching
on screen isn't who you think it is
we're diving into the world of stunt and
body doubles to see what it's really
like to take on daring and risky scenes
on a regular basis
let's have a look at all the scenes you
never knew weren't done by the
performers you thought
we cannot wait to watch fate the wink
saga but keep in mind
the people on screen may not be who you
think which scenes will we be watching
alessandra halbridge as
precious mustafa's character aisha she
looks stunt ready here
don't forget to watch sadie beatrix as
well
because you might just be watching her
body double trina bovenizer
we've been loving the sneak peeks she's
shared in her trailer
and on set tom holland is one of the
best spider-mans
but some credit is due to his amazing
stunt double
greg townley while former gymnast
holland does perform many of his own
stunts
it's townley's job to take on the stunts
that holland can't legally do because
they're deemed too risky and dangerous
my stunt doubles were a dream to work
with because they pushed me to
my limit but in the safest way possible
while millie bobby brown does most of
her stranger things stunts herself
if an injury gets her down like the knee
injury she got during season three
her stunt double cameron pool takes over
she has to be very brave since it's her
job to take on any stunt that could be
too risky for bobby brown
the incredible aerial scenes and stunts
in the greatest showman were mostly done
by zendaya
yeah i never thought that i would be
doing any type of
acrobatic trapeze work in my life
however
like with any high risk scenario there
are times that her highly skilled
doubles were on screen
christa marie jackson is a professional
aerialist
and mallory thompson is extensively
trained in martial arts
parkour and even scuba that's a pretty
impressive trio
when peyton list was cast in cobra kai
she'd never
really fought before her stunt double
janelle curfman
is also her trainer and taught her all
that she does on screen
for the more complex and risky scenes
kerfman not only takes over and performs
the stunts
but brings the little quirks and
movements that list does as her
character to the screen
for consistency one of us gets hurt we
all get hurt
david holmes had a long career as daniel
radcliffe's stunt double
but during the final harry potter film
he injured himself
so badly doing a stunt it paralyzed him
from the neck down
and ended his career i'm definitely
hallows
and it was just a rehearsal that went
wrong and unfortunately i had my injury
some of the stunts you see on screen
can't be faked and the risk is insanely
high
though his career ended tragically
holmes still
loves the profession and even has a
podcast called cunning stunts
discussing the world of stunts now that
is passion
training process is quite challenging
six or seven hours a day lou and lou of
mulan
like many other actors and their doubles
grew and are
very very close the bond is a pretty
unique and strong one
as the two performers come together to
bring one special role to life
lily asphal's skills are quite
impressive for her age
especially considering her stunt double
and trainer is in her 30s
because aspel is still underage it was
rochelle biner you saw on the screen for
the very dangerous stunts in wonder
woman 1984.
i can do it skateboarding was the key
skill that brought william spencer into
the spider-man world
andrew garfield wanted his peter parker
to be a skateboarder
and since spencer was similar enough to
garfield physically
he fit the bill it's not all a breeze
though
since spencer finds the high falls he
does for the films really scary
we don't blame him playing thor is
no small feat and neither is being his
stunt double
bobby holland hanton works out twice a
day and stays on a high protein diet to
make sure he's in shape to double for
chris hemsworth
on top of all that since he's shorter
than hemsworth
he even performs some of the stunts
while wearing heel lifts
but there is always that element of
danger and you do pick up
injuries along the way you know renee
moneymaker's list of stunt credits
is extremely impressive many of them are
her doubling for jennifer lawrence
the hunger games actress is such a fan
of the diversely trained stunt woman
that she will fight to make sure money
maker is her double
money maker has definitely nailed
laurence's mannerisms and movements so
we believe the one
incredible character is actually just
one person
it's not all just battles and jumps zoe
saldana's stunt double from guardians of
the galaxy chloe bruce
had to wear face prosthetics while
performing to convincingly double for
saldana
bruce also studies the way saldana moves
and carries herself to bring as much
accuracy to the screen as possible
when robert pattinson won the best fight
mtv movie award for twilight
it was paul darnell he thanked it's no
surprise since
darnell did many of the major stunts for
the battle that won the award
because it was too much of a risk to
have patinson doing them
we're glad pattinson recognized darnell
publicly and gave credit where it was
due
stunt doubles definitely have to be very
brave to do the work they do
but for many it's a real thrill alicia
velabeli who is shailene woodley's stunt
double for divergent
performed all kinds of insane fights
jumps and falls
including a whopping 66 foot jump that
she did both with
and without wires bella bailey credits
it as her most challenging stunt
just learning a new thing was pretty
cool while the stunts pulled off on
screen are incredible
it's important to consider how big the
risk is for the performers doing them
since somebody has to do the job it's
canadian stunt performer nina loren to
the rescue for x-men dark phoenix
if something bad could happen to sophie
turner on set they didn't risk it and
instead had lorenz step in
stun doubles really are real life
superheroes
for naomi scott's aladdin stunt double
casey michaels
the career runs in the family michaels
is a third
generation stunt performer the major job
michael's had for aladdin was testing
the magic carpet contraption to make
sure it was safe enough for scott and
mina massoud to use
when ree larsen's stunt double for
captain marvel gets ready to head to set
it's not just her phone and wallet she
packs joanna bennett
and many other stunt people have to prep
their stunk bags full of supplies like
cushioning pads and harnesses to keep
them safe while performing
when bennett does arrive to set she
starts the day getting detailed hair and
face prosthetics work done
oh but that's not all keep in mind
many of the stunts are also performed in
heels and skirts
just to add even more complexity to the
job
reynolds is an actor who has had some
bad injuries performing his own stunts
including two broken vertebrae in his
neck
now he usually leaves the stunts to the
trained professionals
will eriksen and alex kiskovic both have
a bit of an easier time disguising
themselves as reynolds when performing
deadpool stunts because of that
fantastic suit
how many people does it take to make a
superhero well
usually more than one in hollywood
actors have all sorts of reasons for
body and stunt doubles
in emma watson's case it's because she
was busy studying at brown university
that's right watson had lots of body
doubles for harry potter and the deathly
hallows since she was so
often in the u.s at school it was
prosthetics and
emma watson masks that help disguise
doubles hannah jones
and joanna whitney on screen they don't
have a home anymore
they're not safe anywhere anymore and
they're on a mission it makes it very
exciting
who was it rocking out on top of the bat
pod in the dark knight rises
catwoman of course only underneath the
suit
it wasn't dan hathaway but her double
jolene van bute
if she weren't cool enough van butte
also used to be
a motocross champion like we said before
real life superheroes
as you can see the role of a stunt
double is not only super cool
but lucrative for bringing intense and
risky scenes to life
did you know about any of these stunt
doubles which stunts do you think are
the scariest
let us know in the comments be sure to
hit that subscribe button to keep up
with all our videos
you